[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's 2020 new you new mean same MVP the
Kelly Academy 2020 campaign officially
begins but we're not running for office
add that check mark on the ballot next
to racks and recreation this is the B
are betting show presented by the
Caesars Palace sports book I'm cabby
Richards
and this is our betting insider Kelly
Lombardi stealin the rocks and
recreation that one has a nice ring to
it so it is 12 4 & 1 which is where my
best bets stand after the regular season
caddy this is a fun week you have to
pick the winner wildcard weekend is
notorious for crazy games and
historically over 85% of the teams that
win the game that's underdog or favorite
also cover the spread you ready yes
let's go right let's start off for the
bills was two and a half of the Texans
total of 43 and a half my man JJ Watt is
back and I went back and forth on this
game so many times
Buffalo 6 1 & 1 against a spread on the
road do I really want to lay points with
Bill O'Brien against Buffalo defense
they've allowed 4.8 yards per game 209
or foot when 8 yards per play 298 yards
per game just 15 touchdown passes they
have 14 interceptions but they're one in
four straight up versus playoff teams
I like the Texans here but I really like
the under Buffalo 5 the last 6 games
have gone under the total the Titans
plus 4 and a half of the Patriots total
of 45 this one's bounced back and forth
between four and a half and five and a
half all week it's hard to get a grip on
you got New England the first time in
the wild-card game since 2009 and
they've only covered three games in
Halloween this has been painful but I've
been telling you guys all season long I
don't bet against Brady and Belichick at
home in Foxborough and here's a fun stat
for you the Patriots by less than a
touchdown at home they've covered 69
percent of their games that's a 38 17
and 3 against a spread on the flipside
the time that played well on the road
this year covering all but one game
Rabil knows new
Lindt yeah yeah you guys see what kind
of gas get so emotional I mean I lean
towards the Titans here but I'm not
gonna bet them I'm betting the over 45 I
got this one at 44 and a half so
somebody agrees with me nine of the last
10 Titans games have gone over the total
and here's another reason I like the
over my buddy Sam tweeted this this
morning I picked out this situational
spot for years patriots and over in
their first home playoff game with its
wild card or divisional it don't matter
and he's right since 2011 yup this one
has gone over the total speaking of the
Pats if you're following along on social
you've seen the changes for the Pats
Super Bowl odds they started off six in
O with that easy schedule were plus 180
to win the Super Bowl fast forward to
week 17 and they were 8 to 1 kaby they
lost to the Dolphins
and after that they were 20 to 1 to win
the Super Bowl
Kelly this was the upset of the year the
Miami Dolphins were 17 point underdogs
in Foxborough you see the Tom Brady
expression on his face now is there is
there a note sorry according to a
website fivethirtyeight.com an analytics
website they it predicts that the New
England Patriots have a 3% chance in
winning the Super Bowl
so is there value in Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick or do you think this era is
over now you embedding them on not to
discredit that website but 3 percent
chances a little low these guys were 20
to 1 they're now 14 to 1 here at
Caesar's Palace so somebody agrees and I
do agree at 20 to 1 that was just a
little bit too high I know everybody on
all the shows talking about they can't
wait for this dynasty to be over I'm not
counting out Brady and Belichick just
yet another trend from our social
account Alabama and New England have
never won a title in the same year but
each one of those teams as you see here
has won its championship since 2014
evidently he's some betters have seen in
this post and the lines got from 2020 to
1 to 14 what do you make of this
movement I mean this is a small sample
size that's only over the last 5 years
obviously mr. Nick Saban is not in the
national championship so that would
implicate the Pats here to be in the
Super Bowl I don't necessarily think
they're gonna win the Super Bowl but
it's speaking in terms of value there is
a monetary perspective here
yes there's value on the packs you want
sprinkle a little bit that's more my
favorite do the Patriots have embraced
omerta for as long as Bill Belichick has
been rocking sleeveless hoodies on the
sidelines one of the few people in media
who Bill Belichick actually talks to we
welcome in Johnson
[Music]
Jack yes it is uh it is widely believed
that Bill Belichick will scheme to take
away his opponents best offensive weapon
yeah so will this have a greater impact
on Tennessee's quarterback Ryan
Tannehill hmm or the NFL leading rusher
Derrick Henry was a well known fact
anytime Bill plays a team he always
takes away their most special weapon in
that case it would be Derrick Henry
obviously and I'm thinking they will
drop a safety down in a box and lock up
on AJ Brown and Corey Davis on the
outside okay now you and Bill Belichick
have a special relation friendly checks
I can text him right now if I needed to
face I'm Bill Belichick no you'll smile
for me he won't smile for you now when
you're playing in Cincinnati how honest
was he about part of the gameplay of his
gameplay right very honest we played
each other three times once in
Cincinnati and twice New England before
every game would meet up at the 50-yard
line
and exchange pleasantries and every time
his message to me was we are running
defensively one double 85 the entire
game so how do you think this bodes well
for rookie AJ Brown he's playing in
Foxborough the Igraine today Maya how do
you think he's gonna vote for that young
man I think it's gonna be okay for him
for the simple fact that I believe
they're gonna try to take away the
Titans best weapon and I think that
would be Derrick Henry okay now you've
been traveling around the country
shooting NFL - Brian which has been
great and you formed relationships with
fellow receivers yes we have featured in
this week's player props offered by
Caesars Palace
let's over the first game of the
afternoon DeAndre Hopkins Oh against the
Buffalo the line is 72 and a half
over/under receiving yards right yes
will he score touchdown plus 150 no plus
one
- 170 excuse me where do you lean on
these two player props I'm leaning on
d-hop they have the over I need the Sean
Walker
deshaun Watson - also lean on the hop
heavily and not just in the fourth
quarter you know because it is a player
game it's win or go home I got the over
I'm not sure one touch
so I'm a little iffy on that part
nothing Chelios explained the defense's
great about this defense here now
Hopkins one of the best receivers in the
NFL and that looks a little fishy to me
but someone who has a little bit of
money on Texans here today I'm hoping he
gets it done for my boys all right let's
go to Sunday's match up we have the
Seattle Seahawks in Philadelphia and
some of them you're very familiar with
you've spoken to many times the season
Tyler Lockett the line is over under
fifty nine and a half receiving yards
Willie score touchdown plus 30 yes no -
150
where are you leaning on these to par
where am i landing who are they playing
they're playing the Philadelphia Eagles
were they playing again they're playing
the Seattle Seahawks and Russell Wilson
they I'm going with the over okay
definitely over over 60 60 yards 59 and
a half and yes he will score a TD today
listen he scored eight this women who
are they playing again the play he gets
the the enjoy a doll I'll be your mean I
mean everything is obviously it's a
smart bit calm a common sense here
they're playing the Eagles lock never I
never bet against your player broths dad
don't you worry okay let's go to the
let's go to the final one we're gonna go
we're gonna zoom out to the all universe
team and Michael Thomas who is the
leading receiver in temperatures in
touch and receiving receiving yards
excuse me the line is over/under 103 and
a half fully score touchdown - 115 no -
105 student at which is 128 yards a game
at home and there are home versus the
Vikings
what are you leaning on this one
particular believable I'm leaning on
Drew Brees which also means the over 103
I'm going maybe 200 he might be here he
might go for 200 targets they might go
for 200 and he definitely will score
matter of fact he might score twice
let's go that's okay find that special
prop over/under one and a half another
category okay please we'll figure that
out here at Caesar's Palace alright
Michael Thomas is receiving prop opened
at 99 and a half yard so betters
obviously agree with Chad Thomas is one
of the reasons why the Saints game has
the highest spread and total of the
weekend let's take a look at those
Sunday matchups
Jack doesn't want to leave the Vikings
plus eight at the Saints total of 49 and
a half the wild-card this entire weekend
is this man right here Dalvin cook I
don't know if he's 100% I don't know how
many yards he's gonna get but we got to
bank on the fact that he's gonna run all
over this Saints defense why cuz this is
too many points no way on New Orleans
too intent against the spread in their
last 10 as a playoff favorite against my
man coach Zimmer in the second ranked
red zone defense
this one is downright disrespectful why
cuz Minnesota has covered five of their
last six at New Orleans I know Kirk
Cousins isn't a good quarterback to know
what that defense is gonna step up keep
it close I like the Vikings and the
under Seahawks - one and a half at
Eagles total of 45 the steam is really
interesting here you have the
Philadelphia injury narrative given
Peterson versus Carol you have Seattle
whose five in O against a spread and
straight up their last five games in
Philly five of their last six meetings
between these two have gone under the
total I like the under you guys gonna
have to wait to the end of the show to
get my best bet you've got questions
we've got answers in this week's mind of
the public Marquez woody wants to know
how do you approach handicapping
complete
you don't change a thing we've been
making money all NFL season this isn't
college football we're not to worry
about coaches leaving
or motivation sure you have to take the
injuries into play and so on but you
keep it to save you keep cash on those
tickets
her dad Oh seven says thoughts on this
tease Tennessee plus 14 and a half under
54 and a half of Minnesota plus 18 all
right guys we've talked about this
before there is no reason to tease those
big dogs for totals ever the question is
why don't you tease New Orleans here
well that's the scary thing this line is
that eight even down to seven and a half
and some spots I thought this one was
gonna go higher so the books would
protect themselves from the teasers
they didn't which makes me like
Minnesota even more I do have a two team
six point teaser for you guys to speak
and that is the bills and Eagles why
because obviously we're going through
those key numbers of three and seven I'm
finally what's your sleeper team in the
NFL to win the Superbowl killer so a B
sleeper that tells me I ain't got to be
35 to 1 who better so I picked a
longshot of course I like the Eagles at
fifty to one which leads into my best
bet
[Music]
that's right the best bets are twelve
four and one the season I got some
making up to do I think I got a little
lazy over Christmas break or maybe the
Giants offense made a couple of mistakes
against this team last week Philadelphia
5 and OH against the spread and their
last two years as playoff underdogs
lifetime home playoff dogs saw the stat
on Twitter doesn't happen very often why
cuz it's downright disrespectful sixteen
seven and one against the spread
favorites of two and a half or less
during wildcard weekend since 2002 in
fourteen against a spread I'm taking the
read that injury-riddled
Eagles and Carson Wentz to get the W on
Sunday night let's recap all of my picks
for wildcard weekend these are listed in
order of confidence on how many units
I'd recommend you bet on each my best
bet we got four and a half you or we
have four units on Eagles plus one and a
half three units on the Titans Patriots
over forty five three units on that
bills Texans under kicking off here in
just a little bit we've got three units
on the Viking Saints under as well now
hang tight on that Saints Vikings game
why because the public is going to come
in on that one tomorrow it's gonna get
better we can get a better number
I'm also betting two units on the Texans
and the Vikings against the spread Plus
that two team six point teaser of the
bills and the Eagles Chad I need some
more context here on this video on your
Instagram feed now this is Hall of Famer
Deion Sanders on the left and in 2005
when he was with the Ravens he played
you in the Cincinnati Bengals in that
game you scored a touchdown
give her your famous Tiger Woods putt
Todd touchdown celebration Johnson
attack she had an interception in that
game but before you explain what's
happening here let's just let's just
roll this cut
now before the explosion of laughter
what was happening there
listen Deon and I never had the
opportunity to play against each other
we have a much true found respect for
each other's craft he is probably the
greatest he is the greatest cornerback
they ever played a game and any time we
see each other in public regardless of
where we are we could be in church we
could be in any establishment any venue
we are going to interact this exact same
thing and talk trash that's what the
king of traffic between you two I don't
know as a good one that is a good one
Jana - 105 favorites you guys are both
wearing tennis shoes nice what was he
thinking about your footwork then say
he's saying my foot my foot wasn't
straight therefore which for you remind
me at my back foot okay so when it's
time for me to go I'd have to straighten
my foot in the time I'd take him gonna
straighten my foot he would lunge
forward and locked me up at the line
okay so if I'm Deion Sanders I hear you
and there's a quarterback he played open
that yes excuse me
but um I would probably throw him
exactly like that being that I'm a much
bigger now you really are I saw that
photo with you and DK Metcalf you guys
you are I'm up there you are understand
if in Miami during the Superbowl when
you're there yes if you have a chance to
light up what's gonna happen again we're
gonna cross passages whoa it's gonna
happen again hopefully there'll be a
Hall of Fame arm to actually throw you
thank you that pass thank you for
joining us on the B are betting show it
has been presented by the Caesars Palace
Sports Club happy early birthday to our
man mr. Chad John 52 52
my heartbreak that is so awesome you
guys just go fine
I think I'm gonna die it Oh
all right guys be sure to follow us on
social add VR underscore betting for all
of my picks and for your chance to win
free be our merch good look at all your
bets and here's your profitable ones
don't mind if I love you thanks
[Music]